it's a new week and that means new video
games and this week a game I originally
thought was an internet joke but it
ended up being an actual game is coming
out telltale spent so much time thinking
about whether or not they could make a
minecraft game they never stopped to
think about whether or not they should
well either way minecraft story mode is
coming out this week and there's a drama
alert going on somebody did something
and your actions could totally change
the course of their lives nothing will
be the same or something minecraft story
mode episode 1 comes out on the 13th but
for real video games are coming out this
week wasteland 2 directors cut comes out
but not just a pc to current-gen
consoles this post-apocalyptic RPG was
the original wasteland that inspired the
Fallout series it was the first RPG to
have split parties for tactical
advantages the sequel was widely praised
so you never tried it before highly
recommended due to the awesome
environmental graphics and tactical joy
press the red button on the 13th Dragon
Quest might not be the most popular game
in the West would it still be loved by a
core group of fans so they'll probably
be interested to know that Dragon Quest
heroes the worldtrees whoa and the
blight below is coming to ps3 and ps4
this week it's a hack and slash game
familiar to dynasty Warriors but with
the characters and monsters from Dragon
Quest so think Hyrule warriors and
legend of zelda same people different
game attack the hearts of the monsters
on the 13th
a few games worth mentioning this week
Talos principle deluxe edition comes to
ps4 in the realm of portal for story and
puzzles so consider it if you haven't
tried it yet grand ages medieval comes
to PS force you can build your own
Empire and rule all of Europe warhammer
40,000 Death Watch enhanced edition is
coming to pcs you can level up all your
Marines and kill those Tyra nerds in the
enhanced edition you'll get access to
new chapters including the imperial
fists black templar and dark angels
mushroom 11 is a sweet experimental
puzzle platformer we play this weird
green mushroom move by deleting parts of
yourself and it simultaneously regrows
it's really cool and you should totally
check this one out right i talked about
Yoshi's woolly world this week as we're
all very hyped for any new Wii U games
in a knitted world filled with many yarn
Yoshi's of varying patterns there's an
evil wizard he's turning all Yoshi's
into bundles of yarn scattering them
across the world so to yoshi's take it
upon themselves to pursue this evil
wizard and rescue their woolly friends
you'll see a lot of similarities to
Kirby's Epic Yarn here not just the
visual style but the gameplay as well
it's gonna be super cute fun become
Yoshi on the 16th finally broforce is
out of early access into full manly
release showcase you miss full-on
democracy obsessed American imperialist
Eagle praising trailer you can take on
the role of RAM bro with all new
campaign missions that all culminate in
a battle with the devil we solely chew
broforce for further details visit
gamespot com release dates are based on
retailer listings and are subject to
change see you next week
America
Oh